So another kind of big classic questions I've been
seeing in the forum's lecture is hosting.
Specifically people want to know if you're not using
Google App Engine, what else should I do?
Or why should you use Google App
Engine instead of the alternatives.
So let's talk about each of those. The first
option is to run your website locally.
And this basically means run this out of a machine
that's in your house, or in your dorm room,
or it's your everyday computer--the same
machine you might be developing,
which works fine for this class.
Basically, the website doesn't
have to be on all the time.
It just has to be on while your submitting
your homeworks and that's it.
For almost every other use case,
it doesn't really make sense.
Some of the big drawbacks are--it's not always on.
The Internet doesn't go to sleep
neither should your website.
It's not always accessible. By that, I mean your
Internet may be broken or power goes down.
There's lots of--you're running in the house.
It's not a data center.
So there's lots of things that can go wrong.
Your IP may change.
Depending on your hosting provider, you may
need to pay extra for what's called a static IP,
and this is an IP that you have to
pay extra for so your IP address.
Basically, the location of your machine
on the Internet doesn't change.
Because you want to have a name
for your website--domain name--
and that domain matches to an IP.
If your IP changes all the time, which it does with
most Internet connections, it won't work out.
Now there's technologies to work around this
but probably won't have a static IP.